en france les indicateurs indiquent une
légère reprise de l'épidémie dans
l'hexagone 6306 cas sur les dernières 24
heures un chiffre en hausse malgré la
stagnation du nombre de personnes
hospitalisées pour une forme sévère d'où
la décision du gouvernement cette
semaine de laisser la possibilité de
prolonger l'utilisation du pass
sanitaire jusqu'à l'été 2022 en réponse
comme tous les samedis les patriotes de
florian philippot vont manifester dans
la capitale contre se passe autre
mobilisation celle adn gilet jaune un
rassemblement à partir de midi contre la
réforme des retraites et de l'assurance
chômage dénoncez également un ras-le-bol
concernant la hausse de la précarité la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat
les gilet jaune qui font un timide
retour sur les ronds-points dans le
rhône ces derniers se donnent rendez
vous tous les jours pour faire entendre
leurs revendications
on voit ça avec louise carvalho et
adrien frontenaud
ils se réunissent chaque jour à 16h pour
dénoncer encore et toujours aux abords
de ce rond-point villeurbanne lés gilet
jaune se mêle désormais aux antilles
passe et autres salariés suspendue car
non vaccinés avec un message inchangé ou
presque j'étais déjà sur les ronds
points en 2010 et avec les mêmes
revendications va dire mais en plus
grave beaucoup plus grave aujourd'hui
parce que
ça continue en fait ça s'arrête jamais
quoi j'aurais même politique et
donc on est là en 2018 et on sera encore
là toutes les manifs du sein dit je
trouve qu'elles ne servent pas à grand
chose au niveau politique si on n'est
pas bien écouté et que là en fait on
veut vraiment se retrouver avec la
population expliquer pourquoi on est
encore là et tout les derricks
gouvernement est en train de faire
depuis deux trois quatre ans là depuis
et qui est l'accentuent depuis la crise
sanitaire qui au départ économiques et
sociaux les anges sont devenus sociétaux
pour de nombreux français car si la
question du pouvoir d'achat avec la
nouvelle hausse des prix du carburant
est toujours centrale pour beaucoup la
crise sanitaire a entamé une fracture
toujours plus profonde avec le
gouvernement tout a augmenté nous les
salaires ne suivent pas on est dans la
précarité il ya des gens qui sont en
souffrance psychologique économique et
qui il est là on va droit où on est
bafouée de partout le gouvernement nous
nous supprime nos droits mon droit de la
liberté dans un premier temps qui est
pour moi très fric est plus important
que même l'argent et a décidé soignants
qui se retrouvent sans emploi qui n'ont
d'autre choix que de se faire vacciner
donc pour moi c'est une obligation donc
à partir de là du moment que c'est une
obligation mais droit n'y sont plus à
l'instar de djamila des milliers de
manifestants espèrent bien se faire
entendre à travers le pays et ne perdent
pas espoir bientôt trois ans après le
lancement du mouvement des gilet jaune